- She is a four time
Grammy winner who sold
over 40 million records
and that's just on her own.
Okay, she sold another 60 million
with a little group
called Destiny's Child.
Never heard of them.
Her latest EP is called
K, it's out right now.
Let's say hi to Kelly Rowland everybody!
(slow jazz music)
(crowd cheering)
Oh every time I see you,
you're like a glowing kind
of beautiful, it's annoying Kelly.
It's-
(giggling)
I like literally every time
I see you, I'm just like
"How does she glow?
Like always."
- You are so sweet, but I'm telling you,
it's the makeup girl, you know how we do?
- Oh, I, I have a whole team,
I call them Harry Potter collectively.
So momma didn't look like this.
Do you and your husband
ever prank each other?
- You know what?
He has pranked me, when
we first started dating.
I remember at my place in Miami
when I lived there years ago,
when it was dark outside
'cause I lived like, you know
on the beach and it was super super dark.
So I would go to one
room like in the kitchen
and he would cut off every single light
in the rest of the house.
And he knew that I'm
like freakishly sometimes
like scared of the dark
specifically in that place.
I've grown out of it now, but all my,
and he would click off
one light at a time.
So it was just some spooky,
weird, crazy Freddy stuff.
I was like, this is so mean.
But yeah, he pranks me all the time,
I just need to get him back better.
- Yeah, I don't do pranks on people
'cause I don't like people
do pranks on me, nope.
Well, when you were on
this show last year,
you talked about wanting another baby.
So, you know be careful what you wish for
'cause you got one.
- That's so fast.
I mean, it's funny.
I can't, I can't believe how it happened
but it was just so, so crazy
how fast that turnaround was.
And I wonder if like shortly after,
I should have to actually
take a note of that.
I should have probably seen
if I was pregnant when
I talked to you huh?
- I mean, I don't know.
Yeah, that's it.
I can't not talk about
that photo we just saw,
isn't that the sweetest thing
'cause my kids are like
a couple years apart.
When you see the older one just hovering
over the little baby one.
Oh, it's my favorite.
- Titan is obsessed with
Noah to the umpteenth power.
Like as soon as he comes home from school
like him wanting to like,
if he hears him just
whimper, "Noah, Noah",
like he's his everything.
So I think he feels like that's his baby.
- I mean, I know his face in that picture.
It's just so much joy and like pride
and he's not even the
dad it's like, but you
you posted this video of your
son, let's see it real quick.
- Whoa, I'm Steve Irwin.
Look at me.
Let me show you some snakes.
This boom snake is highly venomous.
These camouflage themselves
like grand wine snakes.
The camouflages are completely good.
- Oh my gosh.
He is so freaking cute.
Is he training to hunt crocodile some day?
- Girl, he absolutely loves snakes,
loves alligators, everything.
And I showed him one
YouTube of Steve Irwin
and now he wants to watch
Steve Irwin all day and night.
He thinks he's the coolest person,
he's obsessed with Steve Irwin.
- So congratulations on the new EP.
You've been working on these
songs for quite a while, right?
- [Kelly Rowland] Yes I have.
- So why not, so why now?
Why did it finally come to fruition now?
- You know what?
For me Kellz, I feel like, I didn't
I didn't have the worry about a label.
You know what I mean?
And for me, I just really wanted
to create from a free place
and I, and I did and it was awesome.
And not to say that I
couldn't before, it's just
a different kind of space
and it just felt amazing.
And I'm happy that I did.
I'm happy that I released it.
And to be honest, like really
honest, like it's so strange
like releasing music in
this, in this time and space
compared to the time
where we released music,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Everything's so
different wouldn't you say?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I don't know what the hell's happening.
I just said, "Here it is.
And you do whatever you're
supposed to do with it."
Like, yeah, it's so different.
And I feel like in our careers especially,
like just in that amount of
time, things are so different.
How we, how we buy music,
how we re you know, listen to music.
There's been so many different platforms.
- It's so different.
And I was saying that to someone else,
I said, you know, as everybody
like digest music so much quicker now
so it's not like a whole set up process.
Like, and I love the
way this new generation
just releasing music.
Like when they feel something,
they put it out and I'm
like, I'm good with that,
I'm gonna try that and see what happens.
- I love that.
Is it true that you took
over your husband's man-cave
to record this album?
- Yes, I took over my husband's man cave.
Just, I mean, we're in here now.
(laughing)
- How does he feel about this?
- I'm like, it's just such a vibe in here.
He's got these cool
black and white pictures
and like this nice screen on the wall.
It's just a vibe in here and he's like,
"Am I gonna ever see my cave again?"
I was like, "Hoo maybe."
- And now you can just call it you know,
an adult cave, it's just for
y'all don't let the kids in.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Well, I know that a very emotional song
on the record is called "Flowers".
So what's the story behind that one?
- So "Flowers" happened, I heard it
and it just took over in emotion for me.
Of course, it's about a
relationship and making sure
that you have this
beautiful give and take of
of love and affection
and not taking advantage
of the love that is there, that exists.
But it made me think of my mother.
You know what I mean?
And all the things that I
may be wanted to tell her,
I should have told her
and just reminding myself,
it reminded me to really
not take advantage
of the people around me and
the relationships around me.
And when you're able to
look at people in the eye
or pick up the phone to call them, like,
those are moments like,
you know, when they pass
on, you can't get back.
I remember my first
birthday without my mom,
like I literally picked up the phone.
I was like, "Why hasn't my mom?"
And I just froze and I
was like, "Oh my God."
And I called Lala instead, my best friend.
And she was like, "It's all right",
she was like, "Just talk
to her, she's right there."
And literally I did.
And when I talked to her,
the conversation just
continued, continued, continued.
So I do feel like she's
here spiritually, but you
you just wanna give people their flowers
while they're here, while
they can smell them.
And they mean so much to you.
This is so important.
So you know "Flowers" is just me loving
on everybody else that listens to it.
- I love that.
It's, it's been 15 years
since Destiny's child ended.
And that was, it's just,
you're like the most
famous girl group ever,
like, was that, so that,
how crazy is it that that was your start?
And then now you've had such
a huge career after that.
Like not many people are blessed
with that kind of longevity.
Do you just feel massively
blessed because of that?
'Cause that's an, it's a
crazy amount of success.
- Kel, Kelly this is so crazy
that we're having this conversation.
I promise you the day before yesterday,
Michelle called me and we
know each other very well
but I just had this like great like weep,
because I felt so incredibly
blessed that it scared me.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- It scared me.
I know that sounds really
insane but I was like,
"Oh Lord, I'm so grateful for this.
And I'm so grateful for that.
And my family is healthy and this",
like it was so many different things
and I felt so overwhelmed with gratitude
that it just kind of erupted.
And Michelle's like,
"What'd you mad about?"
My eyes were dry, she was
like, "You can't fool me,
you got glassy eyes girl, what happened?"
And so I just told her
and we just kind of like
had this moment, like
'cause I said, you know
I could literally be
twiddling my fingers right now
wondering what's going to
happen, you know, next.
And we're all doing that, you know?
And we were all doing
that at one point in time.
But like, I'm kept, my family
is safe, we are healthy.
It's I don't have to
complain about anything.
I don't feel the need to
And I just am grateful for that.
I think that we have to
remain humble, especially now.
Like, you know, no matter how
high the heights you've seen,
you still keep your feet on the ground.
'Cause it's the sweetest spot to stay in,
you know where you are
and you can still enjoy the heights
of wherever God wants
to take you but yeah,
I'm so grateful.
- I agree.
I always consider everything I
tell my friends and my family
I'm like, "Pf ff"
everything is just, and I've
been saying this for years,
but it, you know any amount
of little success I have,
I'm always like,
"Okay everything else is
just a cherry on top."
'Cause we know so many
singers that are amazing,
amazing dancers, amazing
entertainers that never hit.
And you don't know why or, you know
and everybody works hard.
So it's just like, I
always say everything is
like a cherry on top at this point.
And then it's kind of a
beautiful way to live,
'cause it's how you just made your record.
It's the cherry on top.
You can do whatever you want
because it's your back to
that core thing of just like
why do you love music
and why you're writing,
and it's, it's lovely to talk to you.
I love when you come on the show.
- It's lovely to talk to you.
- I love it.
And I love, I love the cover too.
Cause green is my favorite color.
We have the same name and initial.
I love it.
All right, well Kelly's new EP
is called "K" and it's out now.
You gotta check it out.